failed former president Donald Trump had
a complete and total meltdown over the
Maga disaster in the 2022 midterms
tantruming like a child over the last 24
hours Trump has gone cuckoo and as it
increasingly became clear there will be
no Red Wave there might be a ripple
we're still waiting
but there's not going to be a wave as it
becomes clear that Trump's likely
forthcoming presidential run
announcement next Tuesday at Mar-A-Lago
may not be met with open arms by
Republicans we'll get to that a little
bit later
Donald Trump pulling out all the stops
stops and making a complete and total
fool out of himself here is a real quote
from Trump about last night's results on
news Nation
if Republicans win
he should get all the credit
if Republicans lose he should get no
blame at all
that's not a joke that's actually what
Trump said you've endorsed more than 330
candidates this election cycle tonight
win or lose the results for Republicans
um how much of that will be because of
Donald Trump
well I think if they win I should get
all the credit and if they lose I should
not be blamed at all okay but it'll
probably be just the opposite he he sang
it with a straight face guys
he's not joking it's just like with
covet where he said I don't take any
responsibility
he's not joking uh when they win I think
they're going to do very well I'll
probably be given very little credit
even though in many cases I tell people
to run and they ran and they turned out
to be very good candidates you know
they've turned out to be very good
candidates but usually what would happen
is when they do well I won't be given
any credit and if they do badly they
will blame everything in me so I'm
prepared for anything but we'll defend
ourselves what a victim what a victim
now he said it again with a completely
straight face as Arizona started looking
shaky and people like Carrie Lake and
Blake Masters and Charlie Kirk started
panicking and saying we've we've got to
start claiming that there is fraud here
Donald Trump took to truth social and
delivered a very very strange message
Trump looking disheveled and confused
and gaunt to some degree and again
suggesting that they there is some consp
spirity to prevent them from voting in
Arizona there was no such conspiracy
here's Trump delivering a panicked
message
to the great people of
County in particular don't leave your
line stay where you are they say that
the machines aren't working they say
that they're running out of paper in
different locations throughout different
states there's a lot of bad things going
on stay online do not leave I know you
don't want to be there as long as
they're going to try and force you they
want to delay you out of voting right
they want to delay you why I don't know
and you cannot let them delay you out of
voting so to the people of Arizona in
particular because that's the one that's
come up right now stay online don't
leave already a lot of people have left
and it's very very unfair what's going
on
Maricopa County don't leave stay there
all right uh again we already sorted out
the Arizona stuff at the top of the show
there was really no big deal going on
there issue with a tabulator they dealt
with it and no evidence that anybody's
votes were suppressed in any way and
then Donald Trump posting about his
endorsement record remember what matters
is his own endorsement record to him
impossible to pretend they all won Trump
posting that he was 174 and 9. a great
evening and the fake news media together
with their partner in crime the
Democrats are doing everything possible
to play it down amazing job by some
really fantastic candidates and remember
Trump mostly is endorsing incumbents
and people who are obviously going to
win but do not be confused
the Republican party is really
considering whether it's time to bail on
Trump because a lot of his big
endorsements lost mastriano that was a
critical race lost Oz lost Tudor Dixon
lost
Carrie Lake and Blake Masters may lose
we don't yet know it's along was Lee
zeldin lost uh this was not a
particularly good night for Trump when
you look at endorsements for the
critical races that really matter uh not
a particularly good night Trump knows it
Republicans know it we'll get to that a
little bit later we talk about it all
the time one of the biggest contributors
to climate change is deforestation did
you know that 15 of deforestation is due
to toilet paper production alone
according to the nrdc that's why I love
our sponsor real paper real paper makes
a sustainable toilet paper no trees it
uses 100 bamboo a bamboo stock can keep
being harvested indefinitely no
deforestation real paper is certified by
the forest Stewardship Council for
responsible harvesting of the bamboo
grass used for their paper another
contributor to climate change the
plastic that the toilet paper comes
wrapped in that's why real paper
involves no plastic packaging and best
of all real paper looks and feels just
like normal traditional toilet paper the
cost is similar it is fantastic on their
website you can do a one-time purchase
or set up an easy recurring subscription
the way that I did my audience gets 30
off your first order plus free shipping
go to realpaper.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman at checkout the link is down
below